remember that these are the times we
really need independent media
i would invite you to grab a membership
at joinpackman.com
the prices are reasonable the company is
friendly
and you really are doing a lot to
support our work when you sign up donald
trump
exactly as predicted held an event
that was almost like a rally at the
white house last night something like
two in the morning east coast time
and donald trump says he won donald
trump claims he won the presidency
donald trump claims he won states that
he did not actually win
and trump says that they're trying to
steal it from him they being i guess
democrats you have to see this this is
red alert stuff
this is the stuff of dictators this is
the step to stuff of dystopian
authoritarians this is the exact
situation about which i warned you
donald trump and his family
coming into cheers at the white house
like this
is a victory rally literally as trump's
lead in wisconsin was evaporating
and switching to biden as trump's lead
in michigan was evaporating and
switching to biden
the election results still in question
with multiple paths to victory as of
this moment for joe biden doesn't mean
biden will win but this was not a time
to declare victory
so in comes donald trump thanks people
as if he's won and says there's an
attempt
to disenfranchise his supporters
of course asserting this without
evidence
i want to thank the american people for
their tremendous support
millions and millions of people voted
for us tonight
and a very sad
group of people is trying to
disenfranchise
that group of people and we won't stand
for it we will not stand here
there is no evidence that anyone
is trying to disenfranchise trump voters
and in fact
there's evidence of the opposite from
this trump event
which we will get to trump comes out and
says they're trying to disenfranchise my
voters
later trump confirms he's trying to
disenfranchise biden voters and we will
get that
trump as one example is trying to
disenfranchise by claiming he won states
that haven't yet been called
trump claims he won georgia as i showed
you in our earlier segment
georgia is still counting ballots it is
according to the numbers leaning trump
although the new york times has an
indicator that says it may once atlanta
has counted go biden
the point is he had not won georgia at
this point in time
there's never been anything like it to
support our incredible movement
we won states that we weren't expected
to win florida we didn't win it
we won it by a lot and
we won the great state of ohio
we won texas we won
we won texas by 700 000 votes and they
don't even
include it in the tabulations
it's also clear that we have won georgia
we're up by 2.5
or 117 000 votes with
only seven percent left they're never
going to catch us they can't catch us
trump may win georgia in the end but to
claim
at 2 a.m last night as counting in
atlanta had stopped
that he had won is wrong and when he
talks about suppression
that is a way to suppress activism by
saying i already won it don't even worry
about pushing for the votes to be
counted
we have to see what happens when atlanta
ballots are counted
this is trump assuming a victory that he
didn't have
and certainly didn't have last night we
will see if he ever gets it
how things change so quickly though
because donald trump came out and said
at the same event there's a good
possibility that i'll win arizona
biden's margin has grown in arizona
trump touted a lead in michigan
which has flipped now to joe biden trump
said he was winning wisconsin
wisconsin has flipped to joe biden raise
or thin margins but they have flipped
now understand this when donald trump
came out last night
he was losing arizona but he was ahead
in pennsylvania
there are far more ballots left to be
counted
in pennsylvania than there are in
arizona but
trump comes out and says we need to keep
counting in arizona
but he says nothing about counting
ballots in pennsylvania
with far more outstanding ballots in
particular
from philadelphia pittsburgh and other
democratic leaning areas take a look at
this
we also if you look and you see
arizona we have a lot of life in that
and somebody said somebody declared
that it was a victory for us and maybe
it will be i mean that's possible
but certainly there were a lot of votes
out there that we could get because
we're now just coming into what they
call trump territory i don't know what
you call it but these were friendly
trump voters
and that could be overturned the
gentleman that called it i watched
tonight
he said well we think it's fairly
unlikely that he could catch well fairly
unlikely
and we don't even need it we don't need
that that was just
a state that if we would have gotten it
it would have been nice arizona but
there's a possibility maybe even a good
possibility in fact
since i saw that originally it's been
changed and the numbers have
substantially come down
just in a small amount of votes
so we want that obviously to stay in
play
but most importantly we're winning
pennsylvania by a tremendous amount
we're up 600 think of this think of this
think of this
we're up 690 000
votes in pennsylvania 600 000
these aren't even close it's not like oh
it's close
with 64 of the
vote end it's going to be almost
impossible to catch and we're coming
into
good pennsylvania areas where they
happen to like your president
[Applause]
lots of votes to get in arizona they
must keep counting
and we're winning pennsylvania but only
60 percent has been counted
says nothing about continuing to count
in pennsylvania
and as we told you pennsylvania is a key
state we're suppressing the count
suppressing the mail-in ballots is their
stated strategy it's not
we think they might come up with it's
their stated strategy
and it's because pittsburgh philly and
some other areas that are going big to
biden
stopped counting absentee ballots
overnight they are resuming today
that will hurt trump so trump says
nothing about counting
but arizona he wants the vote to keep
being counted
here trump says counting the votes
is a conspiracy against him i wish i had
more explanation it's completely
unintelligible
and you take all of the others i mean we
have we have so many we had such a big
night you just take a look at all of
these states that we've won tonight
and then you take a look at the kind of
margins that we've wanted by
and and all of a sudden it's not like
we're up 12 votes and we have
60 percent left we won states and all of
a sudden
i said what happened to the election
it's off
and we have all these announcers saying
what happened and then they said oh
because you know what happened
they knew they couldn't win so they said
let's go to court and did i predict this
newt did i say this
i've been saying this from the day i
heard they were going to send out tens
of millions of ballots i said exactly
it's of course been trump who has been
threatening to go to court
i have no idea what he's talking about
it's incoherent
it doesn't make any sense and then
donald trump goes totally in
as he reads vote numbers into the a
fraud has been committed
approach says definitively we did win
this election
remember he didn't win yet he certainly
hadn't won last night he hasn't won as
of right now
and then donald trump starts to allude
to going to the supreme court
to help him by stopping ballot counts
he's doing everything we predicted
so we won there we lead by 76 000 votes
with almost nothing left
and all of a sudden everything just
stopped
this is a fraud on the american public
this is an embarrassment to our country
we were getting ready to win this
election
frankly we did win this election
so our goal now is to ensure the
integrity
for the good of this nation this is a
very big moment
this is a major fraud in our nation
we want the law to be used in a proper
manner
so we'll be going to the u.s supreme
court
we want all voting to stop
we don't want them to find any ballots
at
four o'clock in the morning and add them
to the list okay
it's it's a very sad it's a very sad
moment to me this is a very sad moment
and we will win this and we as far as
i'm concerned
we already have foreign so i just want
to thank you
a major fraud we won
we will be going to the supreme court a
major fraud there's no evidence of
unless the fraud was perpetrated by him
and he knows something he's not telling
us we won
not at that point and not at this time
we will be going to the supreme court
maybe and that could be a disaster he's
telling us the strategy he's saying
he wants the voting to stop voting has
stopped
what needs to happen is the counting he
wants you to believe people are still
voting nobody's still voting
any ballots submitted at this point
would not be valid
valid but the ballots that have been
submitted and not delivered yet
must be counted he's done everything it
looked like he would do
he has i did a segment monday trump will
step up to a podium and claim victory
when there's no victory to claim
he did it some of you wrote to me said
david you're being hyperbolic he did it
he's alleging fraud by the other side
when there's no evidence of such fraud
he did it
he's saying that he will go to the
courts including the supreme court
that's exactly what we predicted
will he get away with it is the question
we now have to ask
the next 24 to 72 hours
will be crucial this episode is
sponsored by
blue chew one of the things i make a
priority on the show is not to
perpetuate
stigma for things that don't deserve it
we've talked about mental health we've
talked about many things where we should
all just be respectful adults period and
we would be better off
and blue chew can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for bluetooth.com
blue like the color blue is the first
chewable with the same fda approved
ingredient
as in viagra and cialis it can be taken
day or night
even on a full stomach since it's
chewable blue chew is prescribed online
by licensed doctors you don't have to go
to a doctor's office
you don't have to wait in line at a
pharmacy it ships right to your door in
a discreet package
they're made in the usa and since
bluetooth prepares and ships direct
it's cheaper than a pharmacy and best of
all
no more awkwardness we've got a special
deal for our viewers and listeners go to
bluetooth.com
get your first shipment free when you
use our promo code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n
pay just five dollars shipping that's
b-l-u-e
chew dot com promo code pacman
to try it totally free blue chew is the
better
cheaper faster choice and we thank them
for sponsoring the david pakman show